Stellt Euch mal vor, jeder Bürger hätte
sein eigenes Punktekonto und Pluspunkte kann
man beispielsweise sammeln, indem man nett
zu seinen Nachbarn ist und häufig seine Eltern
besucht.
Minuspunkte dagegen beispielsweise gibt es,
wenn man sich nicht an Verkehrsregeln hält.
Wer dann nicht in die Kategorie A = “guter
Mensch” gehört, kommt auf die “Schwarze
Liste” und könnte unter anderem Schwierigkeiten
bei der Wohnungssuche bekommen.
Hört sich an wie ein schlechter Scherz; ist
in China aber Realität: Big Data und Big
Brother führen dort zur Massen-Überwachung
schlechthin!
Wie das genau funktioniert, ob die Regierung
ihre Bürger damit tatsächlich erziehen kann
und was die Chinesen davon halten - jetzt
bei Clixoom Science & Fiction!
Hier gibt es jeden tag faszinierende Wissenschaftsvideos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts.
Herzlich willkommen
und danke für den spannenden Vorschlag bei
Whats App!
Da bekommt ihr täglich die Videos früher
als auf YouTube.
Der Link dazu ist in der Videobeschreibung.
Derzeit laufen erst einmal mehr als 40 Pilotprojekte
in China, aber bis 2020 soll das weltweit
beispiellose Sozialkredit-System flächendeckend
eingeführt werden.
Konkret handelt es sich dabei tatsächlich
um ein digitales Punktekonto.
Hier werden die “guten” von den “schlechten”
Bürger unterschieden und das digitale “Führungs-Konto”
hat weitreichende Konsequenzen für jeden
Einzelnen.
Haltet Euch fest, denn jetzt zitiere ich mal
das Ziel des ganzen Vorhabens, das im Regierungsplan
festgehalten ist: "Die Vertrauenswürdigen
sollen frei unter dem Himmel umherziehen können,
während es den in Verruf geratenen schwer
gemacht wird, einen einzigen Schritt zu tun."
Oh je - noch mehr in die Privatsphäre eines
Menschen eindringen geht ja schon fast gar
nicht mehr!
Ab 1000 gesammelten Pluspunkten gehört man
zu den “guten Bürgern”, die sich nichts
zu Schulde haben kommen lassen.
Aber wie bekommt man als Chinese Pluspunkte?
Beispielsweise, indem man anstandslos seine
Rechnungen zahlt, politisch nicht auffällt
und sich auch immer im Straßenverkehr an
die Regeln hält.
Auch das Verhalten im Netz und in Social Media-Netzwerken
wird beobachtet und bewertet.
In einigen Regionen wird sogar überwacht,
ob man regelmäßig seine Eltern besucht und
ob man ihnen finanziell unter die Arme greift
oder aber zumindest im Haushalt hilft!
Erfasst werden sollen alle über 18 Jahre,
die dann alle auch mit Stufe A, also 1000
Punkten starten.
Die Behörden erfassen, ob man sich beispielsweise
in der Freiwilligenarbeit engagiert, ob man
spendet oder ob man festgenommen wird.
Wenn man beispielsweise 1000 Yuan für einen
guten Zweck spendet, gibt es fünf Punkte
obendrauf; wenn man eine Auszeichnung von
der Stadt bekommt, ganze 30 Pluspunkte.
Und das kann sich rentieren: Denn wer den
Höchststand von 1300 Punkten auf seinem Konto
verbucht, bekommt Rabatte.
Beispielsweise auf die Wasserrechnungen, die
zu zahlen sind.
Dann hat man natürlich auch die besten Chancen,
befördert zu werden bzw. überhaupt einen
Job zu kommen.
Und na klar wollen auch manche Schwiegerväter
das Punktekonto des potentiellen Partners
ihrer Tochter wissen.
Wer dagegen auf Stufe C mit nur noch 600 Punkten
absackt oder gar darunter ist, bekommt nur
schwer eine Wohnung oder einen Kredit.
Schon jetzt stehen Millionen von Chinesen
auf der “Schwarzen Liste”, weil sie vom
System für ihre Sünden bestraft werden und
so zur Strafe beispielsweise keine Flüge
oder Züge mehr buchen können.
Quasi Hausarrest oder eine abgeschwächte
Form eines Gefängnisses.
Ein kleines bisschen erinnert das an die Schufa
in Deutschland, doch die gibt ja nur Auskunft
über die finanzielle Situation eines Menschen
und nicht in seine moralische, private und
polizeiliche Vorgeschichte.
Und nicht nur als Privatperson wird man in
China bewertet, sondern auch als Unternehmen.
Um Zuschläge für öffentliche Aufträge
zu bekommen, muss man erst einmal das Punktekonto
der Firma vorlegen.
Die meisten Chinesen nehmen es einfach hin
oder müssen es in dem Überwachungsstatt
hinnehmen; Viele sehen nur die Vorteile.
Das System ermutige einen nur noch mehr dazu,
gute Dinge zu tun.
Und schließlich werde so auch die Sicherheit
in den Städten gewährleistet; zudem könne
man so gut erkennen, ob der Gegenüber ein
“Guter” oder “Schlechter” sei.
Dazu muss man aber auch sagen, dass die Chinesen
quasi mit solchen Ideen groß geworden sind.
Im Kommunismus gab es für Jeden eine Akte,
in der die politische Haltung, Regelverstöße
und private Infos aufgeführt waren.
Zudem ist die öffentliche Überwachung in
China schon seit längerer Zeit sehr viel
krasser ausgeprägt als wir es hier in Deutschland
kennen.
Etwa 180 Millionen Überwachungskameras sind
im ganzen Land verteilt; 2020 sollen es an
die 600 Millionen sein.
Integriert darin sind natürlich Gesichtserkennungs-Programme
und so konnte erst vor kurzem ein von den
Behörden gesuchter Mann zwischen 60.000 anderen
Zuschauern in einem riesigen Stadion festgenommen
wurde.
Büros und Studentenwohnheime betritt man
mittlerweile nur noch via Gesichtserkennung
- und in einzelnen Restaurants kann man mittlerweile
mittels Gesichtserkennung bezahlen.
Auf öffentlichen Toiletten gibt es pro Gesicht
60 cm Klopapier - mehr aber nicht.
Zu den Kameras kommt der gewaltige Datenpool
des Internets, das mehr als 770 Millionen
Chinesen nutzen.
Zudem wird viel bargeldlos bezahlt und so
kommen Big Data und Big Brother zusammen.
Alibaba, Amazon und Co verfolgen das Online-Verhalten
der User und sagen es voraus.
Kurios, denn eigentlich hatten sich Diktaturen
weltweit immer vor dem Internet gefürchtet.
Denn klar, darüber können sich die Bürger
informieren und sich zusammentun.
Doch China nutzt Big Data jetzt eben für
die eigenen Zwecke und will mit diesen digitalen
Möglichkeiten seine Bürger erziehen.
Gleichzeitig geht die Regierung so auf Nummer
sicher, dass das Ein-Parteien-System erhalten
bleibt.
Kritiker vergleichen das Ganze mit Orwell
und warnen eindringlich davor, dass auch andere
Staaten nachziehen könnten.
Und sicherlich ist es auch nur eine Frage
der Zeit, bis die Belohnungen bzw.
Bestrafungen ausgebaut werden.
Wir halten euch dazu auf dem Laufenden.
Wenn ihr kein Video dazu und auch zu allen
anderen Themen verpassen wollt, dann abonniert
Clixoom auch auf englisch.
Denn auch da gibt es immer wieder Videopremieren.
Dafür einfach hier draufklicken.
Und hier geht es weiter mit: A terabyte on
a fingernail - Skyrmions: Revolutionary Data
storage!
- Bis bald hoffentlich auch auf dem englischen
Kanal.
See you soon, stay tuned!